you can't outrun destiny and the destiny
for Netflix's the witcher is another
season based on polish author Andrzej
Sapkowski x' Witcher novels and shorts
that were turned into a video game
series by CD Projekt RED The Witcher was
already lined up for a second season
prior to its official debut on December
20th 2019 the action fantasy show
created by Lauren Schmidt historic takes
place in a medieval world within a realm
called the continent and follows the
lives of three unique but linked
together characters throughout the first
season's eight episodes viewers saw how
the trio were molded by their individual
experiences before meeting one another
and a witcher season one finale
concluded was serious key Geralt hey
weekend with The Witcher Season 1 ending
on that delicious cliffhanger II notes
fans are understandably foaming at the
mouth for any and all information about
season 2 though details are sparse for
the time being here's everything we know
about the second season of The Witcher
The Witcher Season 2 doesn't have a
confirmed release date as of December
2019 however when the series is renewal
was announced it was reported that
production on the new season will begin
in London in early 2020 in preparation
for a 2021 launch date it wasn't
specified when in 2021 the witcher
season - my premiere but it's most
plausible that fans won't be seeing more
of the show until the middle of that
year at the very earliest that said the
production timeline for The Witcher
Season one shows a two year and seven
months gap between when the production
was confirmed in May 2017 - when it
premiered on Netflix in December 2019
while it certainly won't be that long of
a wait for the witcher season to a
production is slated to begin around
February or March 20 20 fantasy date
unless Netflix alots the cast crew and
creatives more resources and funding to
speed things up it's a given that the
major players from season 1 will be back
for the series's second go-around the
Netflix the trio's individual paths
cross at the end of season 1 of The
Witcher and it's of Taos Keys written
works they experienced many trials
tribulations and triumphs together after
meeting well you know this woman of
course you know this woman when Netflix
confirm that The Witcher would receive a
second season on the streamer creator
showrunner Lauren Schmidt history noted
in a press release that the show's team
was keen to quote continue telling the
stories of Geralt yennefer and ciri that
doesn't give us much to go on but given
that season 1 poles
from sub cows keys the last wish and
sword of Destiny it stands the reason
that season 2 of The Witcher will focus
on the first few books of the main
Witcher Sokka 1994 is blood of elves
1995 time of contempt and or 1996 is
baptism of fire but we're getting ahead
of ourselves here the truth of the
matter is that no one involved with The
Witcher has said anything explicit about
the plot of the series is forthcoming
second season speaking with cinema bland
hiss Rick teased that The Witcher season
2 will only expand on the characters and
plots showcased on season 1 saying
season 1 of course carried a lot of
weight because you're setting up the
entire world you need to set up all of
the characters you need to set up the
politics you need to start to understand
what a Witcher is and what they do and
how that's changing in the dynamics of
the world the first season carries a lot
of weight but there's a lot of things
that we did this season the set of
events that we know we want to happen in
season 2 and Beyond in a separate
conversation with games read our history
double down on these comments saying
that quotes all of the relationships
that we've been setting up in season 1
actually start to come into fruition in
season 2 she further noted what's great
about season 2 I can tell you is that in
what we've written the story becomes
much more focused there's a stronger
Drive in the story characters start
meeting and interacting more that goes
well sometimes it doesn't go well
sometimes but it's kind of like all of
those building blocks that we set up for
the world finally start to come together
into something a little more concrete
Hisss rick has also said that she has
seven seasons of the series mapped out
so there's much much more Witcher
goodness to come if Netflix chooses to
make it so check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about The Witcher are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you